that you never worked a cruise did you
ever work yeah no I did one with with
Adam Sandler yeah
that to me that would be a nightmare
because the audience lives with you oh
literally well let me tell you if Adam
was here is he not here he was here
earlier nobody's here do you see him I
think I see him are you okay are you
okay okay
Miss Marino that's why people want to
know so I was on a cruise this is great
too because it was it was like for the
University of Miami so we flew we flew
about we've cruised out from Miami uh on
this cruise and and it was thank God it
was only uh it was like a two-day thing
so it wasn't like a long long but I
remember saying 48 hours I did remember
saying I can't I'm I'm really not good
with hanging out with with people the
same people
like that's what kind of scares me about
doing any kind of that's what's great
about the luck it's it's a lot of people
changing it out but they hadn't been in
Vegas you know yeah it's the same people
gonna come to the show like
so we did this big huge show and it was
a horrible storm and the boat was it was
just it was rocking right in my my this
is only had one prop trunk and it was it
was sliding
on stage no not a joke so it'd go
through behind me and I'd grab it and
then it would go this way and I'd grab
it and I I kind of made a great gag at
it because it was just almost like made
up it was just silly I'd pull a prop and
then it would slide and I won them over
because they were drunk and I always had
visuals and it was and I was and I was
making fun of it the atom comes up with
like a he sat on a stool and it was it
was so rough and you know Adam was just
doing it's like my mom and it was just
it was it was it was just a bad for both
of us bad gig so after the show he says
you know let's go back to the room so we
go back to our rooms and I said you know
next day is you want to go do something
he's like I'm not going I'm not leaving
my room I don't want to see anybody I
kind of feel the same way so we just
kind of hibernated in our bunks and our
in our rooms and never went anywhere and
we finally left and went back to Miami
and we I remember we ordered pizza so
one of my my bits my jacket was
abdominals bit where I had abdominal
jacket and a hat and I'd ordered
dominoes and they'd show up and I'd have
the outfit on the order pizza did you
order pizza like whatever
he said we got to do that bit so we went
back to the hotel and we we did the
actual we call the pizza place and he
had the jacket on the hat it was it was
very a great we we made fun of a good
ending to our horrible Cruise moment but
yeah but it never was good when I do
cruise ships Steve Levine is here do not
book me a Christmas
no cruises no cruises for us at this
point where we are in our golden years
both of us so that's good caratop Howie
Mandel cruise
we started talking about this in the
agent he's like looking yeah this could
be good this is not a great moment of a
podcast
I'm putting these guys on a boat
[Music]